rachel is with us in Wisconsin hey
Rachel how are you hi David first thank
you so much for taking my phone how are
you today
better than we deserve what's up in your
world oh two questions for you one small
one big little small question that I
have is I make about thirty seven
thousand annual have about twenty eight
hundred for my monthly income I'm very
close to finishing baby step one I'm
about two hundred dollars away so I'll
hit that within the next two weeks I was
getting a thousand so in regards to the
stimulus check so my first thought was I
have a fully funded emergency thousand
dollars what I used that stimulus check
to pay my credit card cuz I also was a
little stupid and I bought an iPad and I
put that on my phone plan so that's an
extra monthly payment each month added
to my phone plan which is about five
hundred dollars less your debts mister
debts smallest to largest a minimum
payments and everything but the little
one and attack the little one once
you've got a thousand dollars saved
what's your smallest debt $75 medical
bills done what's the next smallest debt
my $85 credit card done what's the next
smallest debt 96 dollar credit card done
god I've got mosquitoes flying around
you don't you alright well actually I
have Apple earpods at about a hundred
and fifty and those that's my phone
you're an Apple junkie alright and so
that's another one then alright done so
I mean just keep adding up I got we got
rid of four deaths already and I ain't
even got to your iPad and you're gonna
get to it in a minute aren't you I have
a dentist's bill of about five hundred
okay we're just walk through smallest to
largest with your stimulus check or any
other money you get and I think you
probably need to stay out of the apple
orchard I was ready to say that Rachael
no more apples for you you need to go
oranges
I like oranges Oh chill all right good
and don't Hey
and once you pay off those credit cards
cut them up and shut them down okay yeah
you delete it out of your life forever
moving forward no you hear every dollar
budget going kiddo
a little bit I just started the
Financial Peace University yesterday for
the last week wonderful okay well yeah
I'll get you get your every dollar
budget going and it'll help you to work
this you're gonna you're gonna make you
know it sounds like in terms of numbers
of debts
you're gonna clear a whole bunch of
those but 100 bucks yeah a bunch of
mosquitoes flying around you what you're
gonna see is this reducing stress
reduction in stress even though you only
paid off a thousand or 1500 dollars
worth of debt but it's like five debts
or six debts or somebody that's gonna
feel really really good and you're gonna
get a sense of progress a sense of
accomplishment because you are making
progress and you are accomplishing